hey it's thankful thursday and i believe
that it's important for entrepreneurs to
take time out of their busy weeks to
thank the people in their lives for
making an impact you can't do all this
yourself
and you need a team of people to support
you whether it's uh
just emotionally or through actually
providing ideas and resources and
connections to help you grow
so today i want to thank gt bulmer and
gt has been part of my team for for a
while uh he started off in my forums and
was just an active community member and
was
you know people come to the forums and
they're sharing problems and they're
they're trying to understand how to grow
their business and gt was just he was a
force for good and was commenting and
trying to help people out and share his
ideas and provide encouragement
and
you know it's so hard to run a business
and just having somebody
there to say
hey that's a cool idea keep going that
can make the difference and so that's
what gt was
i don't even know how he initially found
my forms but i'm really grateful i'm
really grateful to see that you did
gt moved up and and became my forms
administrator and
was just doing that
bigger you know welcoming everybody and
sharing his stories and encouraging
people
and most recently he's become our author
champion and he works with all of the 8
000 authors who write for my website and
he provides encouragement and support
and ideas and helps them with the
problems they have and
what i really appreciate about gt is
that he really cares
you know he cares about doing a good job
he cares about
about the business he cares about
helping people
he wants people to get a good result
and
and he's a he's a force for good for
entrepreneurs and so i'm really grateful
to have him as part of my team
uh and so gt thank you so much and uh
really appreciate everything that you've
done for my business for all of you
watching i'd encourage you to take some
time today to thank somebody who's
helped you you know write them a note
make them a video send them a quick
email
you know
just show some appreciation doesn't have
to cost you anything just a little bit
of your time you know these people have
helped you get to where you are and uh
and it'll make you feel better and make
them feel great and help you close off
your week on a positive though
you guys like this video you can
subscribe to the channel click on the
link below you can uh support me by
clicking on the link in the description
my patreon link and
leave a comment and let me know what you
think i'll talk to you soon